let's take some time to look at a
blogging app we've designed as well as
some feedback on it in order to look at
which bits of feedback are useful so
here's the app what we're trying to
figure out is whether this app design
works as a blogging platform can users
easily find blogs they want and post
their content easily when we asked users
to find a particular blog or to post
their own content they were generally
confused users had a lot of things to
say about this design I find this really
overwhelming and I'm not sure where to
go I really like the title you should
use Comic Sans for the font I can't find
a way to post here which icon is the
blog I need remember that valuable
feedback is any feedback that ties a
feeling from the user to a specific part
of the app now which of these bits of
feedback are useful for us